[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Hi.
I'm Yufeng Guo, and I'm
here with Ameet Jani,
a Google expert in identity
and access management.
Thanks for joining
me today, Ameet.
AMEET JANI: Thanks
for having me.
YUFENG GUO: Let's dig right in.
So with the increase in
cyber attacks recently,
it's more important
than ever for IT
to stay in control of who
accesses company resources
while still enabling
employees to have
simpler and more intuitive
access to work apps and data.
AMEET JANI: That's right.
Employees often work
outside the office,
as we know, in coffee
shops, hotels, airports,
and from home, so it's important
for companies to make sure
that employees access
apps and data securely.
YUFENG GUO: So let's just
say I'm a chief information
security officer, and I
have a lot of employees
who want to access their
apps from outside the office,
like you mentioned, and
from their personal devices.
AMEET JANI: OK, so
you want employees
being productive
from anywhere, but IT
wants to make sure that
they are controlling
what data they have access to.
So let's take this example.
You have a sales rep using
their personal device
and is about to close a deal.
You want it done securely,
safely, and successfully.
We can see that our sales rep is
using a corporate laptop that's
approved by IT, but they're
also using a personal tablet
device that hasn't
been approved by IT.
The sales rep wants to be able
to use their tablet to access
CRM systems and G Suite, and
corporate IT has to allow that.
YUFENG GUO: Right,
so the employee
wants to use their personal
tablet and access work data.
AMEET JANI: Exactly.
But the problem is
that personal tablets
don't have as many
security controls
as the corporate device does.
YUFENG GUO: And so can
you talk a little more
about the risk of that?
AMEET JANI: Well, the risk is
that if an attacker exploits
the weaknesses on
this personal tablet--
let's say that they
use OS version flaws
and things like that--
they can get access
to apps and data
that they shouldn't be able to.
YUFENG GUO: Got it.
So as a CSO, how can I make
employees more productive
using these personal devices?
AMEET JANI: Well as a first
step, what you want to do
is only give our
sales rep access
to apps on their personal
device if they're
in the right context.
Using Google Cloud's
Access Context Manager,
you can define a policy
for these personal devices
to only allow them to access
some apps while the employee's
in the office.
So if you go to our
sales rep in the office,
they can now access their CRM
system and G Suite applications
from their personal device and
from their corporate laptop.
YUFENG GUO: So that
lets my sales reps
be productive on
their personal tablet
while they're in the office
and can be on a secure network.
AMEET JANI: That's right.
YUFENG GUO: And so this is
great for my employees that
are working in the
office all the time.
But then what about when
they leave the office?
AMEET JANI: Good question.
It's common today
for our employees
to be working
outside the office.
Let's say our sales rep
goes to the coffee shop,
and they log in
using public Wi-Fi.
This is a problem because they
may not be a secure network.
YUFENG GUO: Right, public
Wi-Fi is often not so secure.
AMEET JANI: Public
Wi-Fi might be secure,
but we need to be careful.
Otherwise, attackers can
exploit vulnerabilities
in these networks to get
access to users' devices
or they could easily look
over users' shoulders
to see sensitive data
or password information.
YUFENG GUO: Yeah.
So the way I've always done this
is just by logging into a VPN
when I'm accessing
one of these networks.
AMEET JANI: Well, VPNs
might do the trick.
But they can be
one-size-fits-all,
and they can be a pain
for employees to log into.
We have another way of
giving context-aware access
to applications
using Google Cloud.
Using Google Cloud Services like
Identity-Aware Proxy in Cloud
Identity, we can gather
information from the employees
context, like the device
they're logging in from,
the type of network
they're connected to,
and we can set up a
rule that blocks access
to sensitive applications
on personal devices
when they're in a situation
like this using public Wi-Fi.
So if our sales rep moves from
the office to the coffee shop,
this triggers a context
change in Identity-Aware Proxy
in Cloud Identity.
And when our sales rep tries
to access their CRM or G Suite
app, they can access the app
from the corporate device
because this is a
more secure device.
But for their personal
device, the app
is blocked because of this
heightened security need.
Why don't you give it a try?
YUFENG GUO: All right.
So OK, so that's blocked.
AMEET JANI: Here, you
can see it's failed.
And here, the access is granted.
YUFENG GUO: Got it.
So as employers move around
and their context changes,
that changes their
access to different apps.
AMEET JANI: Exactly.
So now, the sales
rep can still be
productive outside the
office, but their access
to certain apps on certain
devices are restricted.
And as a CSO, you can
see granular controls
to add heightened
security in some context.
Let's say your sales rep
is closing a deal overseas
and needs to travel to
an international country
that your security
team has deemed
to be a restricted country.
If the sales rep
accesses their app
from a network like
the hotel Wi-Fi,
attackers may exploit
vulnerabilities
in the network to access the
sales rep's app and data.
YUFENG GUO: All right,
so I should just
lock down all access to apps
when employees are traveling
to these countries.
AMEET JANI: Not necessarily.
It's often the case
that executives
need to be able to work from
these higher security threat
countries, and they need to
access some sensitive data
to get work done.
Using Google Cloud, you can add
an additional level of security
for high-risk context like this.
In Access Context
Manager, I can set
a rule that blocks all
access to apps except G Suite
Gmail from these countries and
only from a corporate device.
Why don't you give it a try?
On the personal device, why
don't you try accessing Gmail?
YUFENG GUO: Sure.
I'm going to flip
over to Gmail here.
And say try to type in
Gmail, and I hit Enter.
And it looks like we're blocked.
AMEET JANI: You're blocked.
But from a corporate
device, you'll
lose access to the
confidential data.
YUFENG GUO: OK, so
no CRM access for me.
AMEET JANI: Exactly.
But when you check your
email, it'll continue to work.
YUFENG GUO: Great.
AMEET JANI: So now
when the sales rep
tries to access this application
from the corporate device,
everything works as planned.
And the only app they can access
is, of course, the G Suite app
because that's what's
been termed to be safe.
YUFENG GUO: So that means the
sales rep doesn't have access
to all the apps with sensitive
data in this country,
but they can still
be productive.
AMEET JANI: Exactly.
So now, even in these
high-risk context,
you can better keep
employees productive
and your apps and data safe.
YUFENG GUO: This is great.
I think it might finally be time
to get rid of that Legacy VPN.
Ameet, thanks so much
for talking to us today
and teaching me how to
keep a mobile workforce
productive and secure.
AMEET JANI: My pleasure, Yufeng.